all right a new year means new
experiences you can now take an
immersive journey through planet earth
and you don't even have to leave las
vegas rocky is live inside the arcadia
earth museum to welcome us back to
augmented reality hey rocky happy new
year
happy new year you guys see as you can
see as you said i'll get to the reality
this is actually a photo we're taking
pictures because this place is so
instagramable we got it and we're kind
of twinning right now starting the new
year off right yeah absolutely roxy
pleasing so let's take a walk through
here this is arcadia art museum and this
is valentino he is the founder of this
magical place so just tell us first and
foremost what is this experience so roxy
i think
people need to put their talent to work
right it's time to do something good
and what i did is uh i collectively grew
up as artists and we created this
immersive journey so the people not only
can have fun but they can learn about
climate change and they can learn about
what they can do to make a difference so
arcadia is almost a weeheim to inspire
yeah with this beauty
to inform
with this little
i'll show you in a second
activate and also we like to clean
around too
so that's where people can get your yeah
right so
this for example is a tv where you can
scan the qr code you can learn more
about topic or you can also support one
thing or do one thing
right test yourself in case you don't
know about you know overfishing
and the artists so
bring it in 2022 why is this the perfect
experience to have in the new year i
mean like we all know that climate
change is an issue that we need to
address yeah but we always do in a very
negative way and what arcadia wants to
do is actually to make it fun so the
family the kids uh we can all come here
find that perfect instagram picture
but then when we share it instead of
just being like oh i look great in my
picture i can actually say like i am
going to commit or i vow to do something
better yeah share some not spread some
knowledge so we're going to keep walking
so how many rooms can people enjoy in
here exactly there are 15 rooms 15 rooms
each one has a topic each one has an
instagram moment okay and a solution all
right so i'm gonna keep showing you
later on in the show come on for example